Okay.
Uh,
now,
uh,
today we move basically if you move into the 20th century,
um,
uh,
and there's a lot of similarity between the three.
Auteurist will be discussing a nature,
a fried,
um,
and,
uh,
Max Faber.
Um,
uh,
you know,
they're kind of,
you'll be of somewhat different kind of study.
Uh,
but,
uh,
all the,
I mean,
Nicha of course that in 1900,
but he was out of action for 10 years because of mental illness.
Vallish severe mental illness.
He published all of his work in the 19th century.
Um,
uh,
Freud and,
Weber's started to publish in the 19th century.
But these three characters in many ways are very important bridges,
uh,
Tovar.
It's a 20th century social theory.
Um,
and are they,
uh,
they,
did foreshadow,
uh,
a great deal of theorizing,
particularly during the second half of the 20th century,
especially in the last,
uh,
30 or 40 years.
Um,
uh,
I think it also very easy to say the point of departure,
um,
uh,
from Marx,
some continuative,
but basic point of departure from marks in the work of nature.
Um,
uh,
fried and,
and a vapor,
um,
uh,
if I can put it very simply,
the major departure it is,
uh,
that they all,
our depart from Mark's,
uh,
economic reductionism,
right.
Uh,
the emphasis on economic entered us,
which is actually not only marks,
right?
It was a common,
uh,
in Adam Smith's and Mark's,
as a,
as val,
they depart from this and uh,
uh,
the,
um,
emphasize that the problem in modernity is not so much in the economic system
and it is much more,
uh,
in terms of,
um,
uh,
power and consciousness.
Uh,
the problem of modernity is a repression,
uh,
in [inaudible],
um,
uh,
the,
the problem of modern life is,
uh,
that we internalize a,
the reasons for our own subjugation as such.
Um,
and somehow he,
we have to figure it out.
How to liberate ourselves from these internalize a subjugation.
Um,
why do we obey orders?
Uh,
why do avi actually,
except that we are subjugated,
this is the central question.
Um,
I think,
and each,
a fried and vapor are posing.
Um,
uh,
it's again,
a question which has not been really asked.
the other theorists we discuss so far,
they just,
uh,
um,
had a,
uh,
you know,
cvs of society as a point of reference for the good society.
Uh,
now the problem,
uh,
for Nicha Fried and vapor is in US internally in us.
How,
how,
how have you solved the problem and we see in ourselves.
So in a,
this is a kind of,
uh,
introducing the three quarters in some days,
one can say in each of Freud and Viber,
uh,
not only foreshadows a 20th century social theory,
but in some days the order first of postmodern theorist that I had,
the theorist which,
uh,
beginning to come to terms with the uh,
the um,
uh,
um,
or oppressive nature of modernity and try to figure it out,
how to,
uh,
how to transcend that.
Uh,
um,
uh,
now,
um,
I think what I asked you to read for today is probably the most difficult text,
uh,
for the semester,
the genealogy of morals.
And you may have been greatly frustrated by it and probably also irritated by it
because he's a very provocative mind.
Um,
uh,
I hook you did what I suggested,
namely you had a cursory reading of the text before today and now you can go
back to the tax stuff during my lecture notes.
Uh,
and I think that should be,
it should help you to find your way out and to see what he is a reality up to.
Now,
what is he up to?
Let me just foreshadow before I get into his life and work and particularly in
genealogy of morals.
That is another point in which,
uh,
um,
nature fried and they burn can be understood,
uh,
um,
in relationship to a marks.
Uh,
in my very introductory comments,
I emphasize the difference,
right?
The shift of a,
from the economy to the question of power and domination.
But that is a point in which that is a continuities between them and marks,
um,
uh,
nature fried and the dual mainly vapor.
I mean,
labor is a somewhat more complicated story,
but certainly niche and fried and critical theorists,
critical theorists in the,
as we defined this earlier,
right?
Critical theorist that they are offering,
get criticism of human consciousness,
what is in our mind and how did it get into our mind and how,
you know,
and the problem of our consciousness in relationship to our existence.
And this is very much critical theory as it was defined by Hagar and then the
young Marx.
So he galleon marks the marsh of Betty Betty's manuscript,
right?
The marks off of alienation,
Um,
and this is very,
very much coming from this tradition and the central issue is how can we subject
to critical scrutiny and the initials case,
um,
uh,
that is an incredible at them to being made here to try to offer a critical
theory.
We actually does not really have a critical vantage point,
right?
All critical theories of Hagar and marks and 20th century critical theory do
have an idea of a good society of an emancipated human existence.
And they criticize the reality,
the society where they are analyzing from the point of view of this critical
vantage point.
Nicha is different.
Uh,
he is really the most radical of critical theorist.
And in the 20th century,
the theorist which builds the most consistently on it is Michelle Fuoco,
right?
To try to create right a clearly,
which is critical of existence and our consciousness,
but critical without telling you what is good,
right?
But you should be aspiring for and that's exactly what,
um,
uh,
may chase trying to do it.
It's sort of the screening of the circle.
Can you be critical of a situation if you cannot tell what is the good outcome?
Right?
Can you actually subject the very notion of the good society,
the good to critical scrutiny?
This is what he's trying to do,
right?
To offer such a theory.
Uh,
well,
uh,
fried is different,
right?
Freud is a critical theorists beyond the,
um,
uh,
Hagle and beyond mark.
He does agree with marks,
uh,
that,
we have to find the,
some critical analysis which is rooted in our sensors experiences.
And somehow the have to relate the problems of our consciousness to our sensors
experiences,
right?
In this respect,
Freud is very much in the line of Mark's critique of Hagar.
This is not simply radicalizing your consciousness.
You have to confront your consciousness,
which your sensors experiences,
but is different from Mark's.
Because I pointed this out earlier very briefly because in Mark's,
the sensors activity is production.
It is economic activity.
For Freud,
it is our sexual experiences,
right?
And he offers a criticism of our consciousness by confronting us.
Bit are repressed sexual experiences in our earlier life,
right?
So this is a critical theory,
He said,
what you think is in your mind is right.
No,
no,
it isn't.
Right.
You have to think about all of your experiences of your earlier sexual life.
And then when you figure out what you repressed as bad memories,
that's when you will actually,
we'll be able to have a healthier cyclic life,
right?
They'll,
uh,
vapor is more complicated than be,
we'll come back to this Weber's critical theory when we get to vapor and,
and to the question whether he's a critical theorist,
that all that has been highly debated.
Okay.
King,
I think not,
we are ready for Fridich Nicha and I hope this makes more sense now for you.
Right?
But you were reading,
right?
Right.
And let me just emphasize one more time,
right?
The big project in Nicha is to offer a critical scrutiny of human mind,
but not to have any critical vantage point,
right?
To criticize the very principles of good society and good to critical scrutiny.
Where does it come from them?
We have the conception of good,
right?
And good society.
That is his project.
It's an incredible intellectual venture,
right?
As I said,
it is this kind of squaring of the circle,
but he does what he does with a great deal of power and he does it extremely
provocatively,
ivy or put up a couple of quotations for it.
Each are outrageous.
Don't walk out on it,
right?
They are little.
Hold your breasts.
Listen,
this is the outrageous,
what he's saying.
He's at Provo capture.
Um,
he is likable,
so he's only verse down,
so right.
He provokes us even more than Andrew.
So,
uh,
but you know,
deep down he's a very sensitive,
you know,
very humanistic human being,
right?
He provokes about if you'll listen Tierra 40,
you'll figure it out.
That is a something,
but you actually can relate to it when you think what is actually is trying to
get at all.
Right.
Here is a niche.
And let me just very briefly,
Russia,
his life.
He was born in 1844 and the small city of [inaudible] in Germany near Leipzig.
And this is very important.
His father was a Lutheran Minister and the family was,
or clergy looked at and clergy and his bringing up a very,
in a very religious,
uh,
sentiments,
a very religious family.
And in many ways a,
his work is a reaction against the father.
And it is a reaction against the kind of a Lutheran Christianity he was deeply
internalized into.
I think this is very important to understand.
I mean,
I,
I know that most of the people in this room have strong feelings of in the Judeo
Christian tradition,
and he had to acts also Judeochristian tradition.
This is a revolt against the father.
This is a vote against what he was brought up to.
It is an attempt to find himself,
right?
That's what he's trying to get at.
And you have to be a little tolerant about him,
you know,
and he's attempting,
you did that as well.
Your Verda voting against your parents and you were very revolting against,
uh,
some of the fundamental principles you were born.
And two,
he actually enrolls.
So to the University of Brown to become a Lutheran Minister and himself,
he studies theology as it happens to many people actually who enrolled into a
seminary doesn't take him too long to become an atheist.
Uh,
very often,
you know,
the,
uh,
seminaries are the best training grounds for eight days stride.
You beginning to see somehow the complexity of theological thought.
This is what he experienced.
So he quits after a year.
Here he realized is he,
he's on his way to become an eight days.
Right.
And if you're not,
become,
um,
a,
uh,
a minister,
actually this happened to my,
my brother as well.
Uh,
he actually did not quit.
He did finish,
uh,
he,
he was also trained as a Lutheran minister,
but by the end,
uh,
of his theological training,
he was,
I don't think he ever confessed,
but he was actually in eight days.
So I have personal experiences.
Right.
But theology can do through you.
Um,
uh,
okay.
Uh,
then 68,
there's a very important event in his life.
Uh,
he needs the greatest composers of his time,
rehabbed Wagner,
and they become great friends for a time and they become bitter enemies later
on.
And this is very important why this happened.
Uh,
he is appointed as professor of classical philosophy at the University of Basel
before he got actually his degree,
but he doesn't do it for too long.
Right?
He's only teaching for eight years in his life.
And then he,
um,
uh,
recreates a,
and he sacrifices his life to scholarly activity.
Spends a lot of time in Italy,
and if he's in Switzerland,
in a small,
beautiful spot sales,
Maria,
uh,
he also meets in the 73.
Paul Ray and a German philosopher was a great deal of impact on him.
Who introduces him in 82,
two rules.
Salome uh,
his,
uh,
only real but very passionate lover and Ivo say a few verse about this.
Later on in 88,
he becomes mentally ill.
The story of his men,
uh,
beginning of his mental illness tells you a lot about him.
Uh,
he is in general,
uh,
in Italy.
And then on he walks on the street and then he sews a carriage driver beating
the horse venge fully,
and then he suddenly cuddles the horse,
uh,
beginning to cry.
And his mind is God,
right?
It falls deeply into mental illness.
He never recovers anymore.
It's,
I think there's a lot about who Nicha as a human being was,
right?
And how actually how much compassion he could have been suffering,
Uh,
this work,
what you were reading has a lot to do with suffering and gives you a devastating
view.
But human suffering means anyway.
He is in his care of his mother until she dies.
And,
and,
uh,
um,
his care on fortunately for him to his sister Elizabeth,
uh,
and he dies in his home in 1900.
Now,
a bit about Elizabeth Nicha.
Uh,
here she is,
she was born two years software.
Um,
uh,
nature.
Um,
uh,
and uh,
he married a guy whose name was Bernard firster in 80,
85.
And first there was a one of these portal Nazis.
He was a fanatic anti-semite.
Uh,
he was very attracted to this idea of the superior Aryan race and he actually
created an Aryan Colone in Paraguay and moved with Elisabet to Paraguay in a
pure German community.
Uh,
some remains is exist and you know,
if you are a devoted now are Nazi,
you may want to visit product vibe because,
uh,
some of these guys,
he'll still hanging out there.
They look like Indians because of course not very pure Aryan nation.
They are not blown them,
the blue eyes.
And the longer they intermarried with the low cost.
Right.
But anyway,
this is what he wanted to do.
It didn't drink that evaluate.
So at one point,
uh,
he committed suicide and Elizabeth are recurrent that to Germany.
Uh,
well I think it's very important that nature,
after she got married,
broke the relationship with,
it's just a,
he just could not stand,
uh,
his,
brother in law and his antisemitism.
Though you've,
you'll see some of the citations,
which sound very antisemitic.
He was very intolerant about antisemites.
Uh,
uh,
this was one of the reasons why he broke his relationship with Richard Wagner.
Um,
but in 94,
uh,
Elizabeth created the niche or archive and nature was insane.
Um,
and uh,
he had a lot of unpublished work manuscripts.
He put it together into an archives and he abused it as much as she could.
Uh,
she turned into a right finger and that with the rise of Nazis and now see an
admirer of Hitler and he put together a lot of,
uh,
um,
Nicha test in order to fabricator Nazi ideology out of Nitsa Nature.
And some therefore have been reading for a very long time nature as an ideologue
of Nazis.
So did other of Hitler who actually even attended the funeral of Elizabeth in
1935 and she died.
Now I think,
uh,
people who read the nature care of fully and to have seen now niches or
original,
um,
uh,
verche published rather than selections by Elizabeth,
have a great deal of doubt where the niche or has anything to do with
narcissism,
though the story's complicated.
Now,
uh,
here we come,
a nice triangle,
Lou Salome,
poultry and Rick nature,
they'll,
I should show this picture of after Freud,
uh,
remember that a watch a watch on it.
It is a very fry Dan kind of presentation.
Louie solo may or ruined the middle and Frederick Nicha,
uh,
um,
on the other side of the picture.
Now a loophole and Friedrich,
yeah.
Uh,
for Ray is actually comes from a very varsity Jewish family,
German Jewish family,
uh,
for reasons which is beyond me or occasionally an hid first to him when they
already broke up.
Uh,
uh,
as,
the,
the English a psychologist,
he was a German philosopher.
And anyway,
he became very good friends.
Uh,
at one point,
I mean,
you know,
initiative was an imbecile block or a son.
He Fall in love with people and then he broke just strong glove or struggle,
a strong Keetra.
There was nothing in between.
Uh,
but anyway,
the idea of Janell algae,
which is probably the mean bs in niches where it's coming from for Ray,
that he introduced this wonderful young and very smart young lady,
Lou Salome to Nicha and he falls desperately in lover of your 10.
This happened in 82.
She was 21 years old,
as I said,
very beautiful and Vonda food is smart.
Um,
and the veil nature was hoping to marry her.
I mean I use was opposed to the idea of marriage,
but,
uh,
you know,
he's writing letters to pour a kind of not over there that that is a
relationship going on between Corey and Lou that he was to marry her probably
for two years or something.
And uh,
anyway,
um,
uh,
I think,
by all likelihood the daddy's an interesting loft triangle going on here for the
vial,
but then she's impossible.
And Louise,
I seen woman and at one point she just cannot take her his insanity anymore and
he moves to Badlin ellipse for Avaya foray and then do,
he's also opposed to marriage.
You know,
we are late 19th century.
He Ryan that is adequate or ideas about sexuality and marriage,
but then he's still married a this guy,
linguist on gas.
And if she was also a very smart woman,
she at one point said they wrote a book together,
re Nicha and herself and she never published that.
Uh,
she said this one,
I like this,
the spidey man,
the joy in the book by the three,
we never,
you know,
I,
as far as I know,
it never had.
And I don't important person in his life.
Uh,
Rehab Wagner,
uh,
well,
a niche of as a music fanatic in an arena or at the end of his boyhood.
And then he rather,
uh,
Wagner's piano landscape of Tristan and Isolde.
Uh,
he just fall in love with that.
That was the music he was looking for.
Um,
he buy,
he was,
he was a hero worshiper.
A,
that's why,
you know,
people,
some people read steel in him,
kind of throttle on us is to you like strong,
beautiful people who are here.
Roy,
he can do act,
do heroic act like degree.
Uh,
right.
a beautiful young man.
Powerful.
Right.
And she,
Roy drag the gods,
the Greek gods.
That's what he,
uh,
really,
empire.
This is what he found in Wagner's music.
Yeah.
A rejection of the roost.
Rosie,
any kind of sentimental ism of Italian music and the,
in fact the classicism and coldness.
So,
um,
and Beth tentious Nash,
uh,
in the music off of Beethoven and what he found is something,
yeah,
I knew in a bag now,
so he was attracted to Vagner.
Um,
and,
uh,
um,
as he was becoming a,
actually increasing the antisemitic,
uh,
under the influence of his last wife,
go see mark who was the daughter of France,
lists the composer and,
and laws,
a yak 50 evo person.
Um,
uh,
and also,
Ragnar was changing.
He was becoming in some ways what kind of more Christian or something,
and he was writing this,
I actually have to contest love the opera Parsifal niche check would not take
it.
You know,
I just was impossible for him.
So then they break,
uh,
he could not stand Wagner's antisemitism anti could not stand Barsi fraud and
the kind of expression of,
I don't know anybody ever hurt Prosti file.
No.
A lot on the easy stuff.
Um,
it's a,
it's a sounds like an auto Cory on,
uh,
it has some Bach Ian kind of elements in it.
Um,
uh,
and uh,
it's about,
uh,
the sacrifice of the lamb of God,
Jesus sacrifice and the performance of the mass.
And the call,
uh,
oh Jesus.
Blobbed as such,
I mean,
I,
anyway,
this was certainly a niche of us,
not a buyer for it.
Now,
Justin Brewer at about,
uh,
his first book,
the burst of the Tatra d,
uh,
bitch,
ah,
um,
uh,
as I said,
he was a great admirer of the Greek civilization.
Um,
and if he,
if he had a,
he,
his idea is that the whole human history is given by the struggle between a on
Nizhan and Apollonian principle.
Now you're in Asia and means,
right,
your sentiments,
you act out of your instincts.
And Apollonian means the reason as such,
and the,
you know,
the contrast,
enlightenment,
enlightenment is reason.
It's a big journey of Apollonian principal over the Dionysian tens it ball and
he kind of rejected.
This is why he's also kind of postmodern three.
He Rejects Enlightenment and enlightenment,
excessive rationalism.
And this is why actually he liked Wagner because he thought in Vagner,
uh,
the,
dot.
Your nation at the Apollonian components are being combined,
right?
Uh,
passion and reason are put together.
Um,
uh,
and Wagner loved the book.
Then he dies the book.
Uh,
1979,
1879,
a human all too human,
which starts from Voltaire and the sort of lay effication of the free thinkers.
Now he's a free thinker.
Uh,
and he also breaks with Romanticism and,
um,
and uh,
for follows ray.
And he said,
well,
what we have to do is to subject the Christian idea of good and evil to critical
scrutiny and not to accept that there is some general principle of good and
therefore he trusts to develop the genealogy of morals.
Now,
as you can see by now that Nicha are on collision course,
right?
A Nicha is now subjecting the very core of Judeo Christian tradition to critical
scrutiny.
Uh,
while,
uh,
Ragnar is writing policy fall and,
being,
uh,
the holy grail and as key disease,
Wagner,
assuming Leven has not read the book,
uh,
he,
he heard about it and rejected it.
He did not buy anything about this.
Now,
this is a niche,
just housings,
uh,
Sales Maria.
He went there for the first time in 81.
Fell in love with this and spend time there until he became ill.
He also,
the genealogy of morals he wrote to his mother.
Finally,
I found a lovely,
you're spot on earth.
And,
um,
he,
uh,
was greatly inspired.
This is about,
he wrote the book also Sprach Zara to star does spokes that are too strong.
Um,
uh,
this is a kind of a book which is a central attack on Jude Judaeo Christian
morality,
but he found repressive and wants to get out of it.
His hero is our across Strava,
which is modeled after the Persian prophet Zoroaster.
And he calls him that the first of immortalist dare to be immoral is what you
have to do.
That the,
he tries to find the middle way right within the repressive grew,
they were Christian morality.
And Nicholas,
he,
he wants to get a,
uh,
doesn't want to reject everything.
Uh,
and that's where he beginning to develop the audio of the Uber.
Man,
I wish we would have more time to talk about this.
Uh,
um,
uh,
the Uber Man,
she's basically the person who brings his life under his own control.
It's not quite what you think the Uber Man shares,
right.
The stereotypes about the Uber Manch that this was the kind of Nazi idea of the
blown the Germans,
right?
Which are superhuman.
Well,
nature has a philosophical notion of the Uber match the Uber Man.
She's the person who achieves south master you who basically the alienated
person,
right.
Who is in control of his own life.
Right.
And can express himself authentically this out or oppressive civilization.
That's,
that's the Uber match in a vague,
this is a book.
It is an idea of a boat harbor.
Not a passive would,
huh?
He this lie boot highs as much as she like this slide,
the Judeo Christian tradition that the problem with the boot,
his boss,
that it is still passive.
He,
he wanted to have an active with his new ride.
Somebody who becomes a master of its life through action,
acting out its feelings and its,
uh,
even,
sensual,
uh,
essence in,
in,
in life.
Um,
uh,
and therefore he,
he can overcome what he calls the attorney return,
right?
And he can overcome the island low of these,
you know,
this is again comes from almost marks.
Slide reified consciousness.
The lay fired word can be broken.
There are no rules,
right?
You can,
I,
you can realize yourself in the world and you are not ruled by the external.
And now he's ready for the genealogy of morals.
I have some 12 minutes for this.
What are the major contribution?
Well,
he reconstructs the,
the,
the methodology or genealogy,
but he takes from ray and uh,
and he discovers what he calls the origins of morality.
Uh,
and then he introduces a difference.
Okay,
what is the difference between good and bad,
where this is coming from and good and evil that this is coming from.
And he compares the two ways,
how this dichotomy that some behavior is good or there is bad,
some behavior is good or that is evil,
that this is coming from.
And this is the essence of the genealogical method,
right?
He does not need that critical vantage point.
The good and the evo distinction can be criticized from the good,
bad distinction point of view and the good,
uh,
and,
and vice a versa.
You see,
ah,
this is the essence of genealogical mattered.
Um,
as a full core veal interpreted,
give me an ocean,
tell me what is right,
right.
And what I do,
I take the same conception back in history and then they'll show what you think
is right just or mobile has been at one point of time regarded as evs.
What you should fight for and tell me what you think is evo and I go back in
history and I will show you instances that what you think is evil was actually
admired and was seen as ethical,
right?
This is the essence,
right,
of the genealogical mattered,
right?
That you compare two ways,
how morality is being constructed and you are criticized one from the point of
view of the other,
this south taking sites that do actually use them as such.
And then he develops,
you know,
the kind of origins of the notion of evil out of slave morality and restaurant
demand.
And then it comes to one of the most controversial issue,
the idea of the blonde beast,
the bird of gray.
Um,
and the origins of ideals of what can be easily.
I think,
again,
I'd have to ask for your patients.
And then the idea of Eva Manchuria and finally the origins of punishment and,
uh,
Beth consciousness and deal.
Okay.
So as I sat here,
reconstruct the genealogical mattered.
I think it's a wonderful sentence how the whole book begins.
The are on the norm to ourselves,
the knowers and did good reason.
We have never looked at ourselves,
right?
This is critical theory.
What he suggest,
right?
You think you know a lot of stuff about,
you know,
Hobbes and Locke and Rousseau and now nature,
but you don't look at yourself,
look at yourself,
be critical of your own consciousness and especially the major step here,
try to subject the very conceptions what you think is ethical to critical
scrutiny.
Is there,
does this idea come from uh,
uh,
and he said he is real argument.
Is that the origins of the term good and evil?
Good.
And do we have to discover how it actually was constructed and not with,
uh,
a more superior principles.
So therefore,
what we need is a critique of moral values.
This is wonderful.
Now,
the value of these values should be subjected to critical scrutiny itself,
right?
And not only the values,
but the values behind the values.
You know,
there is an unending criticism,
um,
uh,
in,
in the process.
So this way what nature can do,
or he believes he can do,
is to offer a critical analysis.
We sell some ultimate value.
He does not give you ultimate values,
but is the right value is,
but he does that without becoming in a holistic and to say anything goes.
Not we can discover the miseries of the world.
We can be upset.
He could solve the,
I was so upset to cuddle this horse,
which is beaten,
right?
You can have compassion.
Uh,
and he,
uh,
he sure this was an inspiration for full call.
All right.
The difference is in the origins of good and bad and good and evil.
Well,
I think this is a,
a pretty,
uh,
probably the most straightforward part in the text.
What you have read.
Yes.
He said,
thou then the use the verb good.
You,
Oh van often see that God has something to do with it being not a [inaudible].
He said,
[inaudible] that's not so it has nothing to do with non egoistic in terms of its
origin.
It was constructive and non egoistical later on.
And she said,
where does a good coming from?
It is coming from a master race.
A master is which show store itself as good and defined the dose who were
subjected to each rule.
Uh,
usually dark standard,
uh,
natives,
as bad.
Um,
uh,
that is where the notion of good and bad is coming from.
Um,
but that's different with priests.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
he was studying to become a minister and he really disliked priests,
priests,
you know,
very in these dark hoses,
you don't know what they are,
not the chivalry.
Alastar cratic kind like the Greek as Sandy,
Garth's and God's right,
uh,
who are confident in themselves.
And,
uh,
therefore,
the chivalry can Edisto cratic distinction,
right?
Which was that the physical,
the good,
you know,
um,
uh,
the beautiful body,
the man and women,
uh,
of,
of Greek antiquity,
um,
uh,
or could see themselves as good and others who were not as good as crippled.
They've are bad.
Now,
uh,
the police are powerless and his powerlessness,
at least to his credit,
he shut off those who have power,
right?
And now those who have power as seen by the power,
less as evo,
not simply as bad,
but as evo.
So now the contrast is not between good and bad,
but between good and evil.
But what turned that around,
uh,
is,
the power relationship and now comes the slave morality.
And now he said it was the Jews.
That was the priest,
the nation,
the nation of priest.
Um,
and the origins of Christianity a brought about this reversal saying all the
doors who suffer are good,
only poor.
The powerless are good,
right?
The reach and those in power are evo,
Um,
and,
uh,
the slave revolt of moralities,
each ad begins with the Jewish rev world.
Uh,
and this has a,
a thousand years of history.
And you know what,
that was victorious.
This is the dominant mortality of our times.
And he said,
this leads to the,
and,
and here you can see this is not an antisemitic statement.
This is a criticism of the Judeo Christian morality.
And in fact,
the real target is Christian morality.
That's why he said this is the horrible paradox of God on the cross,
right?
Uh,
that that is,
you know,
when,
when you sort of turn right,
uh,
adores doors without sin to carry the sin of human kind,
the Sev crucifixion of God for the salvation of mankind,
right?
And this is a,
these restaurant he meant a very strong team on that is no proper English or
German word for it right now,
beginning to see the enemy,
not simply as bad as,
you know,
I don't care that it's bad.
I defeated,
but it is easier.
It may even defeat me and now comes the boom beast.
And other approvals,
Sandoz statement,
the center of all knowable,
racist from cannot fail to see the beast of prey,
tobacco,
inefficient blonde beast,
a writer and heavily [inaudible] around to spoil and victory,
right?
As I said,
Chiro via worship.
But let's uh,
you know,
uh,
is this the German blonde?
He said,
well,
Europe feud with horror,
the reaching of the blood Germanic beast for centuries,
but then he asked watch together fully,
right?
Although between the origin and manage people and us Germans,
that is cast the,
an idea in common,
let along blood relationship,
right?
This is not Nazi ideology,
This is a kind of a argument that being powerful being the realizing yourself
is,
uh,
is actually what is the job or what you should be striving for a well,
I think this is a very important try this,
this last sentence,
14th here.
Uh,
I'd,
what happening in European situation is a kind of a leveling right?
Today we see nothing but wants to expand,
uh,
the organic thinner,
right?
You're not as strong as the statute in Greek statue to her.
Right?
And better nature,
right?
Clever.
I'm more comfortable and more medial car.
And he said,
well,
I had a bad day.
It smells what?
I'm horrible modernity right now they become own major and all the same and we
cannot feel fill ourselves.
Right.
And then,
well this is a very nice,
sporty,
provocative,
but you know,
think about it then.
That is just nothing strange about the fact that the lamps smear a garage door
Varsa large birds of prey.
But that is no reason to blame the large birds of prey for and the little lab,
there are no lamps.
Circle each charter,
these words pray our evening meal and whoever is least slide a birds of prey.
I'm was like the opposite like us.
The lamb is good,
isn't it?
Right.
Those who dominate is bad and doors we are the suffering God,
the good ones.
Bad.
Yeah.
The bird afraid as finance,
they don't bear any garage at all towards was good labs.
In fact,
we love them,
right?
Nothing tastes better than I can.
All right,
well as I said,
this is disturbing,
but I think the point is what he is calling for,
right [inaudible] of individual.
And the,
and his desperation that in modern world we cannot fulfill ourselves.
And here comes the workshop.
Our ideals,
the ideas are fabricated.
He said in this workshop,
realize are turning weakness into accomplishment.
In Paul Importance,
uh,
um,
mark to retaliate is being turned into goodness.
Though you are only in important and you beginning to construct your pretense
has good.
You are not good.
You can't do anything about it.
And submission to people you hate.
That's what you call obedience.
Not because they,
you really accept their superiority because you are afraid of them.
And then you construct a good notion out of this obedience.
This is a good word.
Um,
now he said there are,
they are also talking to love your enemy,
um,
and our sweat by the assays,
right?
It's a big lie.
You don't love you on it.
You hit the gestalt of them.
You say you love them and me and values,
right?
That's what he said.
You know,
this is the workshop,
right in which,
uh,
the ideas are created.
This is where they call it the triumph of justice.
Uh,
you don't hate your enemy.
Oh,
no,
no.
You hate injustice,
right?
You create your enemy as in just right and are there other thing?
Well,
this is why anime and he's stronger than me.
Um,
well therefore he said the workshops where ideas are fabricated,
they s change of lies and again,
better get out of here.
Clean Air,
less stark.
True,
not lies.
That's the point.
And Eva,
man,
she's the one which will,
right?
Because either manages,
uh,
he said,
well,
a good and bad,
good and evil food together.
Now the good and evil is a dominating us.
They are,
the renaissance was brilliant.
It was reconstructing ride the,
our classical idea.
Um,
but Dan Kim again,
you said the Judah three [inaudible] gain again,
be careful,
not anti Semitic nose.
It's again more like a against looter.
Then again,
Jews is that thanks to the basically proletarian German and English arrest song,
Chemo moving around car that the reformation,
right?
That's his real enemy here.
And he said,
well,
if we don't have time to labor on this very briefly,
origins of punishment,
we have to forget.
A forget is we have to suppress memories,
which were bad.
And in order to suppress,
uh,
well,
that is a magnum namel techniques,
uh,
that means that we are actually have been,
is the most useful way.
How we forget what we have to forget.
We have to remember,
right.
Um,
you said these Germans,
donation of thinker me,
the memory for themselves,
the fool matters.
Uh,
stoning,
breaking,
gone deals reaping.
But Bart and trend pink to this by horses.
All right.
I have to finish it now here.
Uh,
but I hope you get sort of the bottom line,
right?
The bottom line is have a radical critical theory does not need ultimate value
to be critical of a false ideas and lies get shoes.
And the ideal is the person who can fulfill itself right in the world and
conquer the world as such.